moi je voudrais rebondir sur ce que
benjamin a dit vous savez de s'être fait
avoir comme le se fait avoir vendredi et
en plus d'avoir faire un score qui est
très sympathique non d'avoir le coeur de
revenir je laisse moi parler tu arrêtes
m'a jamais donné par le choeur c'est
lille oui d'avoir le coeur de revenir
lendemain alors qu'on m'a prévenue à 13h
et d'allègement ça prend beaucoup
d'énergie beaucoup de coeur le second
c'est tout cas et je mérite un peu de
respect surtout qu'à chaque fois on sert
de moi pour l'audimat et ont même unis
c'était dur et des
finances en conclusion toi c'est vrai
mais je te poser serait ton avis je te
dirai ça franchement tu ne pousses pas
sur un plateau on dîne ensemble vendredi
soir tu me dises a coûté très cher chez
des amis je me détermine à
quoi comme conclusion quand tu dis je
fais le show je fais le dit matt et on
me dit tout le temps tu en tires quoique
en conclusion écoute moi je suis pas en
agence de communication ces soirées ont
écrit des trucs pour l'énergie
qu'est ce que c'est il est beaucoup plus
sympathique quelques souvenirs je fais
de l'ange the time of the pop à des
questions de politiciens voilà pour les
retrouver je n'ai pensé que müller vous
deviez
une femme vous savez très naturel savez
toute ma vie j'ai dû faire avec ce que
j'avais dû renoncer
mais sans ses maîtresses
attendez attendez quoi vous n'avez rien
reçu pas encore assez mature où tu vois
je te montre
parce qu'elle a déjà déjà cet entrain de
bourse à partir
c'est vrai ces légions de rentrer
vouloir partir ça
pas encore nombreux je pense que quand
j'aurai mes enfants je serais obligé
parce que bon mais là j'ai même pas de
soucis fins
[Rires]
s'il habite je vois ça très bien voulu
trouve à talons quand même afida les
deux là mathieu évacuer les mineurs
étaient piégés tapas tu vas pas
recommencer avec sacha feiner
s'il vous plaît je supporte tribunal de
grande instance
pourra mais ça je ne sais pas je tu sais
pourquoi je fais un magot que c'est mon
ami oui et on a fait des choses sinon
sinon on se bat donc je lui dit rien
parce que c'est un copain depuis
longtemps et j'adore guillaume et
j'adore mathieu donc saison qui l'avait
vu faire allez c'est bon pas un peu de
ça est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un à une
question un peu plus
sa bague
oui tu parles beaucoup de respect de
faire attention à la personne mais en
fait tout à l'heure tu arrivé tu nous
dis tu respectes que les gens qui
peuvent donner du travail depuis merci
mais c'est de finir non mais attends
chez toi
tu peux avec benjamin tubal ken bâtés
minami tu manques de respect non pas des
mécanismes qui peuvent te ferme et un
avec mon visage maintenant c'est tout
raymond chésa vraiment tu dis je suis
naturel tu peux pas être naturel est
dire si tu fais pas travailler non je
vois déjà tu fais le choix tu vas pas me
la fais moi je ne laisserais bien tenter
pas aimé aller moi je vais faire quoi et
par mes soins
jeudi cette machination tous les médias
hier je disais
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas sympa avec moi tu es mon ami
et benjamin j'ai travaillé les
résidences mais par les tutus arrête
parce que là c'est pas juste
parler dire comment tu m'aides pas les
mêmes choix de foca
justement ben c'est pour ça qu'ils ont
eu pendant
ce que je voulais dire on est en france
et on pensait pas c'est pas sympa et
c'est moi pareil c'est pas sympa il a
voulu traduire oui mon énergie mon grand
quand je disais exactement je n'écoute
pas soit ils continuent à et continue je
vais je voulais dire en fait
effectivement il continue jusqu
alors je voulais dire en fait que quand
t'es qu'un me critique au théâtre du
petit jour et qu'il n'est pas il
aperçoit un cristal ou lellouche
depardieu je ne prends pas en
considération ce qu'ils peuvent dire
et comme on est booké depuis quatre
semaines en belgique à deux fois la
province était bouclé par
là le loser
le bouquet d'un garçon dont la nasa
alors viens par ici